لذا، جيك أولاً عما هو موجود في هذا الشريط
ولماذا يُنظر إليه على أنه دليل بالغ الأهمية
للمستشار الخاص،
لذا قام مراسلو CNN باولا ريد كايتلين
بالانس وكايتلين كولينز بكشف هذه
القصة وما هو شريط صوتي
أرسله المستشار الخاص جاك  سميث
أه منذ يوليو 2021
الرئيس السابق ترامب الرئيس السابق
ترامب في بيدمينستر منتجعه في
نيوجيرسي اجتماع مع بعض الأفراد
الذين يكتبون سيرة ذاتية لرئيس
أركانه السابق مارك ميدوز الآن
على الشريط، قيل لنا أن دونالد ترامب
يتراجع عن ذلك  مقال يوصف فيه مارك
ميلي رئيس هيئة
الأركان المشتركة بأنه يمنع ترامب
من مهاجمة إيران وترامب غاضب
من هذا ويحمل
وثيقة ونسمع حفيف
الأوراق التي لسنا متأكدين مما إذا كانت هي بالفعل
الوثيقة المعنية لكنه يشير
إلى وثيقة سرية من شأنها أن
تدحض كل هذا لكنه يقول إنه
لا يستطيع مشاركتها لأنها سرية
الآن، وسبب أهمية هذا الأمر هو أن هذا
يبدو وكأنه يشير إلى أن دونالد
ترامب كان يعرف ذلك لمجرد أنه أحضر
المستندات  معه من البيت الأبيض
إلى أي من منتجعاته لم
يرفع عنها السرية تلقائيًا وأنه
لا يملك القدرة على رفع السرية عنها
بمجرد التفكير فيها كما
ادعى على قناة فوكس ويبدو أنه
يتناقض مع ما قاله عنها  لقد تم
نشر هذا الأمر بشكل علني أيضًا، بما في ذلك خطابنا
لكايتلين كولينز في مجلس المدينة
قبل بضعة أسابيع، لذا، بغض النظر عن المخاوف القانونية، ما هو
نوع المخاطر التي تهدد الأمن القومي بالنسبة
لوثيقة كهذه التي
من المحتمل أن تكون علنية مثل تلك التي
شاهدها محلل عسكري
ينضم
إلينا الآن الفريق المتقاعد مارك هيرلينج، لذا فإن ما نعرفه عن هذه الوثيقة
العامة هو أن الخطط التفصيلية
لخطة هجوم إيرانية هي مواد سرية
تعاملت مع مواد سرية
تقود القوات في المنطقة قبل
ما الذي يخاطر به الأمن القومي من
الكشف عن ذلك  جانب من موقع آمن،
حسنًا، الغرفة الأولى، أنا سعيد لأنك بدأت
بالقول بعيدًا عن
الآثار القانونية لكل هذا لأن هذه
قصة مختلفة تمامًا، وأكثر ما
يقلقني كمستخدم
للمعلومات السرية هو مقدار ما يقدمه هذا
أعداؤنا، ما مدى إمكانية
التنازل ليس فقط عن تلك المستندات الموجودة
في غرفة بها مراسلون يكتبون
كتابًا، ولكن أيضًا إمكانية
حصول الرئيس على هذه المستندات
في نادي الجولف المزعج، كما تعلم
أن هذا هو الشيء الذي  إنه لأمر مدهش
بالنسبة لي أن هذا ليس بالقرب من
موقع مركب شراعي صغير حيث يتم
الاحتفاظ بمستندات سرية، فهو يشاركها مع
الآخرين في هذه الحالة المراسلين ولكن مع من
شاركها أيضًا وما الذي
تحتويه داخل هذه الأوراق التي
تعلم أنها يجب أن تفعلها  مع
العودة إلى الجنرال مارك ميلي
بسبب بعض الأشياء التي أوصى بها فيما يتعلق
بخطة طوارئ إيرانية أه
إذا كان هذا حوار بين
رئيس هيئة الأركان المشتركة
المستشار العسكري الكبير يعطي
توصيات محتملة لاستخدام
القوة العسكرية ضد محتمل  الخصم الآن
الأصدقاء مهتمون بذلك، والأهم من ذلك بكثير أن
الأعداء مهتمون
بذلك، لذلك إذا كانت هذه الوثيقة
متناثرة، فهي مجرد سيئة لا توصف
بقدر ما
أشعر بالقلق،
لذا فقد تعلمنا شيئًا آخر من
التداعيات المستمرة لـ
تسريب الديسكورد هذا الطيار الذي كان يشارك
وثائق سرية على الديسكورد
ذكرت صحيفة الواشنطن بوست أن
وثائق البنتاغون من ذلك التسريب أظهرت أن
إيران تخطط لزيادة الهجمات على
القوات الأمريكية في سوريا أه أتساءل لأننا كنا
نراقب موقف إيران
في المنطقة  لدينا أيضًا بعض
حلفائنا يعيدون إقامة
علاقات دبلوماسية مع إيران.
ما هي حالة العلاقة الأمريكية الإيرانية
هناك؟ وتزايدت
فرص المواجهة المباشرة في
ضوء كشف مثل
هذا،
وأعتقد أن ما نتحدث عنه هنا  في
هذه الحالة مع مقال الواشنطن بوست
والتسريبات المحتملة من خلال
نص حسابات سارة ليس مجرد
اشتباك مع إيران مباشرة ولكن مع
الوحدات شبه العسكرية التي يستخدمونها أه
في مناطق مختلفة في هذه الحالة سوريا
الشيء الذي لفت انتباهي
بصراحة جيك في  كان هذا في هذا المقال الذي نشرته
صحيفة واشنطن بوست هذا الصباح
زيادة في استخدام ما
يسمى EFPS المتفجرة المخترقة،
وهو نوع من
الأجهزة المتفجرة المرتجلة التي بصدق، حقيقتنا، واجهت
قواتي عندما كنا في العراق عندما
صادفت الميليشيات العسكرية الإيرانية  الحدود إلى العراق
واستخدمت هذه الأسلحة الخطيرة للغاية،
فهي أكثر فتكًا بكثير من
العبوات الناسفة التقليدية، حيث يمكنها اختراق بضع
بوصات من الدروع، وقد رأينا بصدق
خلال فترة من الوقت عندما
كانت الميليشيات الإيرانية تستخدم هذه القنابل في العراق،
رأينا المزيد  خسائر بشرية أكثر مما لدينا
ببساطة من العبوات الناسفة، لذا فإن حقيقة
إمكانية استخدامها في سوريا واستخدامها
ضد الأكراد هي أه وضد
نوع المعدات التي
تمتلكها الولايات المتحدة والشركاء الأكراد في تلك المنطقة أمر
خطير للغاية